formula one's debut one of the Hot
Topics at the Las Vegas Chambers preview
Las Vegas event yesterday so when
Formula One takes over the strip in
November check this out it's suspected
to generate 1.2 billion dollars for the
economy
and did you know that's twice the
economic impact expected from the Super
Bowl that's coming to Allegiant Stadium
next year Grand Prix CEO Renee Wilm
what is a fascinating about our race is
the NR sport generally is that we are a
Super Bowl at every event we take this
super bowl-like event throughout the
entire world throughout our calendar so
you know just sit tight and see how
amazing it will be yeah Formula One
takes over this trip November 16th
through the 18th